a heavy security presence on the streets
of hawara in the occupied West Bank the
scene of this shooting
while the events leading up to it are
disputed with local people saying it
began with just a quarrel and police
saying the man 22 year old Amma miffley
coming at their offices with a knife
there's no doubt from the video how the
shooting itself happened a struggle
between the men both grabbing the
officer's rifle as they separate the
weapon falls to the ground while the
officer apparently pulls out his handgun
shooting at mifflay as he lies on the
ground
he would die half an hour later
the cold blood he took out his gun and
killed him I was devastated my heart was
shattered when they shot him he was
defending himself the worst part is that
he shot him in his heart it hurt me
[Applause]
this was the funeral just a day earlier
for two Palestinian Fighters one of them
a field commander from Islamic Jihad
with the upsurgeon fighting leading to
near daily killings and fears of this
simmering conflict escalating out of
control
high level of violence in the occupied
West Bank
and Israel in recent months including
attacks against the Israeli and
Palestinian civilians increased use of
arms and settler-related violence have
caused grave human suffering
according to the UN
2022 already counts as the bloodiest
year in the occupied West Bank since
2006 a year that isn't over yet The
Killing has brought immediate
condemnation from the Palestinian
authorities who describe it as
cold-blooded murder there's also been a
strong reaction from the EU office here
saying it's Gravely concerned about what
it calls an excessive use of lethal
Force Rob McBride Al Jazeera occupied
East Jerusalem